on a commencé à faire un bilan Lucy a
touché sur l'action femme debout 230
femmes plus 60 aujourd'hui ça fait
presque 300 femmes qui sont venus sur
l'action femme debout à Saint-Pierre
à au port à saint-endré et ici sur le
judo même il y a eu 945 gamins et
aujourd'hui il y a 150 gamins tu fais le
compte on a presque après lu passé au
chaudron il y avait 150 gamins qu' l'a
accueilli et il parti dans un centre où
on fait l'handicap il y a eu une
quarantaine de gamins elle a eu elle a
eu des visitationnelles elle a une
réunion conseil générale avec 4
personnes on a fait un total de 2000 à
peu près 2200 2300 personnes qui ont
gravité autour de l'événement luci de
Cos pour nous on est fier de faire ça on
fait parler du CH pendant une
semaine
c'est pour les enfants aussi c'est pour
lesants justement ça leur donne un petit
peu déjà ça leur fait un petit peu
d'animation de recevoir une championne
et puis ensuite ça les motive pour la
suite bien avec Lucy
oui alors il faudra remercier Luc tout à
l'HE avant qu'elle parte moi j'aimis Luc
vu que c'est la triple championne du
monde et donc j'étais super content de
la voir c'est pas tout le temps qu'elle
vient à la rodo du coup c'est l'occasion
pour nous de la voir une championne
c'est bien parce
que tu peux gagner des
trophées après tu peux gagner des
médaille ben ça sert à apprendre de
nouvelles techniques moi je trouve que
c'est super d'être une championne à
champion c'est bien on peut gagner des
coupes des médailles les filles ce sont
un petit peu championnes al alors
qu'est-ce qui est plus fort c'est les
garçons ou les filles les garçons ah bon
les filles sont pas forts championnes
elles sont un petit peu forts résumé ben
une image de de respect et puis aussi de
de partage parce que voilà moi je suis à
10000 km d'ici j'ai une carrière de haut
niveau je suis une championne et je
viens
ici à la rencontre des des jeunes judoka
et de et des et des femmes du territoire
donc le
partage là-bas du gâteau tu préfères le
goûter ou le judo le judo tu le goûter
non le judo moi le
judo